مهل وعيد كيف تتعامل سلطه الانقلاب مع كل
هذا طبعا هي دوله ذات اهميه استراتيجيه
خاضت عددا من المعارك ضد الارهابيين
الاسلاميين هي الدوله رقم سبعه من حيث
انتاج اليورانيوم والولايات المتحده لها
حوالي 1200 عنصر او عسكريه وكذلك
الفرنسيون والالمان لهم وجود عسكري ولذلك
لايجار هي من افقر دول العالم
وتعتمد على مساعدات
عموميه بمقدار مليارين دولار سنويا
دوله مالي نفس المعامله ومرت الامور بسلام
ان شاء الله لن يكون هناك مشكله باذن الله
لو في تكاتك بين الشاب
والسلطه انا اعتقد ان الامر الجدي
والتهديد جدي من قبل المجموعه الاقتصاديه
للدول الغرب افريقيا او ما يعرف بالهواش
تدرس تدخل عسكريا رئيس
لم نسمع شيء عنها لكن لعلك قد يكون فيه
تفاور المجلس العسكري في النيجر اليوم
اصدروا بيانا ذكروا في بانهم يعارضون اي
تدخل عسكري
هنالك مهله او انذار لمده اسبوع وهذا ما
يعطي هامشا للتفاوض هل فعلا
محليا انا في العاصمه في وسط العاصمه ما
في شيء ما في مخي ما في شيء مخيف بصراحه
يتوقعون هذا لانه
يقلقني هو ان
الازمه في النيجر قد تاخذ بعدا دوليه نرى
روسيا الاتحاديه او جزء منها ربما ينظر
ينظر الى فرص يستغلها وراينا اعلاما
ورايات روسيه
رفعت في المظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي
شهدتها النيجر خلال الايام الماضيه
الامر الاول ما المفاوضات ممكن سيكون هناك
انفراج هذا الذي نحبسه لو حدث والامر
الثاني الامر يبقى كما هو كما حدث في مالي
هذا الذي ولكن تدخل عسكري ليس وارد بمعنى
الكلمه لا يكون سهلا جاء على لسان الضيف
السابق فان هنالك هامشا ليتفاوض ولكن
اختلفوا معه بشان تم استعداد لتدخل ضغط
مجموع الاقتصاديه لدول الدول الغرب
افريقيا ينبغي ان تؤخذ على نحو جديد